[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts I
mean let's let's start at the beginning
it's the only way to do this
Adam and Eve if you guys know that story
okay if you know that story this is all
gonna go over your head tonight
if you haven't seen a special
um go watch it it's it's my boy Ari
shaffir
um he's got one of the best comedy
specials that I've seen in a long time I
think it's your best work ever I really
do Rock Solid dude it's so good I went
to a seminary called the Yeshiva in
Jerusalem for two years after high
school so you go to study if you want to
become a rabbi uh spoiler alert it did
not take
are in Shakira special on YouTube it's
called Jew okay it's about learning
about Judaism through comedy that's the
new way that comedy special is going to
get out it's like we gotta have to see
him and teach you something that's a
great special orange shaffir special Jew
uh even Kanye likes it I saw it it's
it's very good Kelly I think it might be
your best work go on in here he comes
Ari shafir how do I get up and give you
the middle give the middle okay I saw it
I came I watched you do it live my buddy
Steve uh he's Catholic he's a comic and
uh I made a Catholic joke once and he
got I got off stage he was he had enough
of it you know so I got off stage he was
like Ari what do we have to do to make
you stop making fun of campus and I was
like
one thing
archive here took the comedy World by
storm this week dropping his first
full-length special in over five years
the specials already closing in on
almost 3 million views on YouTube so I
wanted to hear from the entire comedy
community thoughts on Ari shaffir Jew we
took this question in the joke World
Community page and asked 145 000 comedy
fans their thoughts on the news special
and in this video we're going through
some of the best responses and also
playing some highlights from the show
you showed me uh you know just like a
little bit of it on the phone it looks
[ __ ] it looks amazing we've got
thousands of candles and put them up
there to make it to make it go with the
uh with the sort of the theme of the
thing but it's just a stand-up hour and
you guys are gonna love I'm really
excited about it it's [ __ ] hilarious
best special you've seen since
[Laughter]
there was definitely some level of
pressure on this special given that re
fans have been waiting over five years
for this to come out but based on the
general reaction of these comments it
seemed like Ari over delivered this guy
said loved it it's both a deep dive and
Ari's experiences and views of religion
as well as a silly and absurd take on
the human struggle to make sense of
things Ryan Shaw said just saw Ari live
last night his hour was completely
different no repeat jokes from the
special that dropped days before very
impressive that's insanely impressive
and honestly really good to hear as a
comedy fan that he's already running a
whole new hour Blake said I like Ari's
specials actually having a topic where
the whole special is based around one
topic like his Netflix double special
about childhood and adulthood ju fits
that shoe very well and already Nails it
for 90 minutes amazing 9 out of ten the
ones with the you know the sideburns the
long the curly fries as my black friend
calls it
yeah my friend Miss Pat she came to
visit me in New York she'd never seen
one there's very few Hasidic Jews in the
black ghetto of Atlanta
so she saw her first we were talking she
just goes like
she was like Ori she don't say my name
but she's like uh
she goes why that man has curly for us
I'm like those are not garlic fries she
goes what they do and I'm like first of
all
the grammar on your people is on another
planet
Oh and about you people I don't mean
black people I mean non-jews
yeah Jews are racist but we don't see
skin color we see IQ and income level
yeah boys that's all you guys are you
ever hear that word
[ __ ] it's Yiddish for uh nongju Yiddish
is like Jewish Ebonics
there's also lots of comments on the
overall length of the special do is 90
minutes long which just to reference
another really good YouTube special
Shane Gillis live from Austin that one's
48 minutes long so Ari almost doubled up
the length of Shane's special which some
people really like some people didn't
like this guy said Ari's best work
longer than usual specials but still
great love the theme of religion another
one said Ari just knows how to be funny
on stage man really long special and I
was locked in the whole time I then
deeply angered said a little too long
for me just in terms of sitting down to
watch something stand up is nice for an
hour unless you're actually there
otherwise I'm just looking at different
angles of the same person and the same
backdrop in the same theater that I had
been for the past hour it gets sort of
mundane to even need to watch Santa bet
all if the comic isn't physical and when
you consider how unimportant that design
is this is one of the more interesting
stand-up backdrops I've ever seen but
still didn't hold my attention for the
whole 85 minutes
so this guy who called Ari special is
too long just wrote the longest YouTube
comment in Internet history also it
being 90 minutes you know it's a 90
minute special on YouTube but in in this
world where like less is more and you
know you put a lot of us are putting out
30 minutes because they're like oh you
can't can't have do you you know the the
viewer is not going to be engaged for
all 90 minutes yeah I found myself I
watch it in two parts but I found myself
being like I have to go back and watch
this it's I had to try to cover all of
it that was the problem when you do
something it was like you can't leave
some of it out you can't be like I
didn't want to finish and people like
you didn't cover what kosher is right or
like Hanukkah so it's like there's
certain it's definitely plenty of stuff
I left out but I didn't want anybody
going what the [ __ ] why didn't you
mention this well yeah yeah little
things like how come there's two
different kinds of Jews Not only was
this special very funny but it was
extremely educational I can honestly say
as a [ __ ] myself I learned a ton about
Judaism just watching Ari's special and
really just about Ari as a person this
guy said probably the best religion
based comedy special ever that's a
really really big statement to say but
it's hard to disagree with Donnie said
hilarious and educational I learned just
as much about Judaism from it as I did
Scientology and Mormonism via South Park
and this guy said very Jewish material
and delivery was on point I can see the
work that's been put into this one so
you heard it here first Jew is Jewish so
another thing you know that I think
about that special is it's genuinely
something that like I've always wanted
to try to do but I'm too dumb to do it
or maybe I don't I'm not putting the
effort into research but you literally
learn and laugh and I know that sounds
gay and I know that's like but lit like
it's it's Colin Quinn the only ones that
I've learned and lasted Collins was
great yeah because also it's like does
that like I don't want to say it but
like the one-man show it ain't that it's
not a one not one man show either it's
just like hey here's just stand up it's
kind of like when you watch Regan or or
Nate bar gatsi yeah and you're like oh
are they clean you're like oh I guess so
yeah but that's not you're not going for
a clean comic do you feel any guilt that
you're special killed Aaron Carter uh no
how long did it take you to prepare that
special five years and a half so what
five and a half years ago was the plan I
want to make a special about Judaism
yeah I went to I went to Edinburgh the
uh festival and I saw these like themey
hours and I was like they're cool it was
interesting for sure but then it was the
same time it was like you guys don't do
it right you're like getting serious in
the middle for like 20 minutes right
which it's lame it's fine UK comedy is a
solid 15 years behind us right
you've been working on this I feel like
for a long time yeah and a long time
five years of intentional work on one
working special
so like
yeah and Now podcast I put it away for
like a year plus for covet and took it
out and figured out all the [ __ ]
jokes that are too long and so I could
see it fresh again if you want to start
doing always now but like
yeah then Kanye comes in right at the
[ __ ] Finish Line at the buzzer it was
also fun seeing Ari do the typical
podcast rounds that come with putting
out a special nowadays going on all
these different shows to talk about it
in just a past week alone he's been on
Chrissy chaos are you garbage Tuesdays
with stories good for you Madden Shane
secret podcast whiskey Ginger the
bonfire and The Joe Rogan Experience I
mean the venue was so cool what was that
called what was it called again roulette
roulette yeah intermedium in Brooklyn
yeah yeah and we dolled it up awesome
dude the set design when it was gutted
it looked kind of like [ __ ] when they
took it all out yeah man you had to have
some you had to have you know when like
someone has that design eye where they
know how to like see a room and go okay
I get it because after they peel that
apart I was like whoa it's not I mean
sorry roulette to the people that own it
but it was [ __ ] look like [ __ ] it's
fine it's just the way this lady Lauren
Halper and she's the designer and she's
never done specials before but it was
she was like rose to it yeah it didn't
seem like I guess it looked amazing if
you want to look side by side Samurai
also recorded there and they looked
nothing totally different yeah did he
use the same lady no no yeah no he's
Comedy Central that's like [ __ ] dude
yeah it's just a backdrop of New York
right [ __ ] off
dude they always use the same comments
don't you use like the same intro music
all the time these are the same like
hacky uh what what is that like um
license free music or whatever oh my God
before Oh my god dude we found a
license-free music but it's not
happening the early versions of it and
then they just started using that same
stuff it was like two years to use it I
think you should use it for Daniel Tosh
promos 100 I'm like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you guys yeah they don't get
it it's [ __ ] labeled as aren't they
oh you [ __ ] dorks let me tell you
something Comedy Central is doing fine
without you they're soaring to the top
of the ratings they are killing it
they've got that new show
if you haven't seen it yet I would
definitely recommend go checking out Ari
shaffir Jew it's available right now for
free on his YouTube channel and speaking
of YouTube channels if you're looking
for one to stay up to date with the
entire comedy world at once like if a
channel that would cover all your
favorite comedians on your favorite
podcasts boy are you in luck you're in
the right place consider subscribing to
this Channel right now joke World hell
you could even be featured in a video
like this one of your comments could be
read on the channel you can get your
opinion out there about these Comedians
and their specials what's better than
getting your opinion out there subscribe
to your joke world that's better it's
it's one of the same
thank you for watching this video and
I'll see you again Monday with the
comedy news
[Music]